[Music]
gold face masks what does this actually
do if anything so gold does have some
anti-inflammatory and antibacterial
properties
but the skin claims are a little over
hyped it's super trendy it's cute on
insta but i would say save your money
for something a little bit more
affordable okay let's declare this
beauty or bust bust
i have seen this everywhere you take a
beautiful stone and massage your skin do
you recommend gouache massage washa is
actually a traditional chinese technique
that has been used for centuries i think
it's great for skin you know it's not a
face lift or anything but i think it's
really really great for that little bit
of improved circulation and de-puffing
so gua sha beauty or bust i'm going to
say beauty
hydrated plump skin is always trending
so we've teamed up with dr farhang and
rock skin care to help you get it i'm
always looking at the skin care
ingredients the active ingredients and
the science behind it and that's why i
recommend rocks new hydrate and plump
serum capsules what's interesting is
rock actually conducted a clinical study
on 34 women and 100 percent
had visibly reduced lines in just one
week will this use up 100 of my credit
card bill you can find it at walmart for
less than 25
dr sheila i give that a beauty
[Music]
you